on the sunny south coast there's an
election in the air and the Liberal
Democrats believe this time they could
be in the running hoping their new
leaders pledge to stop brexit altogether
will push remain voters of all
persuasions in their direction joe
Swensons first speeches leader setting
expectations extremely high there is no
limit to my ambition for our party and
our country and today I am standing here
as your candidate for Prime Minister
personal attacks on the leaders of both
main parties underlined her rejection of
the prospects for any future coalition
people across Britain deserve a better
choice than an entitled Etonian or a
1970s socialist suggesting Boris Johnson
was sexist and that remain voters cannot
trust Jeremy Corbyn now I do Faraj might
be breakstep by name but it is very
clear that Jeremy Corbyn is bracelet by
nature throughout this conference the
party has not missed an opportunity to
parade its new recruits or to boast of
its brexit unity in contrast the two
main parties Swinson is hoping that the
recent parliamentary defections could
come to reflect a realignment in the
wider electorate that the party can
become a political refuge for former
conservative and Labour MPs but for
their voters as well but has the sea-air
led to some overconfidence could their
extreme remain position prove to be as
step too far the test will be in places
like Harrogate in North Yorkshire
conservative since 2010 but where
fifty-one percent of voters backed
remain in the referendum and you can't
just suddenly cancel the vote of 17
million people
I was remain and then I wanted remain
but now it's like we've got to just
respect and just completely leave now I
think slowing down the process whether
it's to leave or to stay isn't it's only
a good
it's just going to create more
frustration in the people of the country
Liberal Democrat members will leave this
seaside gathering with a greater
optimism than they've experienced in
years but having been told that
government and the mentor brexit is
within their grasp there is also
significant scope for disappointment
Tom Rainer Sky News Bournemouth